et maintenant voilà mais comment le
service de com de l'elysée peut laisser
passer ça poussera chaque vidéo même
tourné à l'arraché à l'iphone elle est
validée sur valider là il part de samuel
pas tiqué quand même un drame il tient
une vidéo de youtube heures qui sont qui
sont qui sont des youtube heures marc
enfin c'est honteux de laisser passer ça
franchement
oui sur l ouest est vrai que ça en même
temps pour le couvrir de très très
mauvais goût mais j'ai trouvé et en plus
ils n'arrêtent pas nous dire les mesures
barrières comme les youtube heures et
tout ça est lui même quand il a
marseille il avec avec des marseillais
il a pas de masque il n'ya pas
distanciation sociale il est dans un
truc super fermé et franchement on
n'arrête pas de nous dire fait ça fait
ça il ne fait pas lui-même il devrait
être un tout petit peu plus exemplaires
ça serait bien quelqu'un lui rappelle
qu'il est président la république parce
qu'on ne peut aucunement to me choque
j'étais hystérique chez moi lui qui fait
les petites vidéos avec max faille
carlitos même pas qui c'est de youtube
heure là après
apprennent avec justin bieber qui a
plein de bagout c'est comme ça il pose à
côté hockey sup lire maintenant il
fallait pas non il parle de sa mère
pattie d'être truquée qui coulait garde
à vue l'a poussé au test c'est un
président résultat tu secours à quand on
respecte pas un président qu'est-ce qui
se passe il se prend une claque dans la
rue voilà où on en est quand il prend
une claque dans la rue c'est la france
qui me rappelait que dans la rue
franchement ce qu'il fallait annoncer
une ont tout ça parce que mon avis à
deux débiles de l'accueil qu'on lui fait
dire alors sur les jeunes ça va
cartonner de ça il est président il
représente une fonction je sais pas
peut-être comme un vieux con mais jamais
j'aurais vu mitterrand ou un autre
président avec max la menace
la coupe du roi
de marie brillant qu'il faut évoluer
alors mais oui alors si le président
venait dans cette émission alors mais ça
n'a rien à voir s'il met sur pause et
bien parlé là ils relèvent des défis
malgré l'écart abyssal
et sûrs et
il a compris un truc aussi c'est la
puissance des réseaux a compris qu'il
cède à delighted parce qu'il y avait des
bills de la com qui lutte pour gagner
des élections fonctionne sous peu les
jeunes croient que je crois que c'est
même pas alors c'est vous dire c'est pas
des débiles doha comme il franchement il
fait ses trucs cela je pense à un
dilemme carlito il est bien où elle aime
bien tout ce qui lui laisse à leur
chalet j'ai demandé justin bieber est
arrivé en france il a dit j'aimerais
rencontrer macro macro qu'est ce qu'il a
dit oh bah oui bien sûr t'imagines chez
nous une star américaine star française
qui arrivera aux états unis en dix ans
j'aurais bien passé c'est joe biden on à
dire akwaba bien sûr c'est que j'essaie
de le faire sans déconner oui c'est vrai
j'aimerais beaucoup voir jo bats tu vois
valérie compte ici vaut lui là ils ont
tous vu aucun respect ce matin c'est
ridicule et